[Music]
last sunday oprah interviewed meghan
markle and prince harry about their
experience stepping back from the royal
family
and a lot of the interview was about the
pain megan had
suffered at the hands of the british
press they are truly evil to her that
whole country talks about megan like she
stole their man
which i guess she did
now i look at meghan markle and i see a
nice lady in well-tailored clothes
but when the press writes about that
same woman all of a sudden she's
difficult
not appropriate unsuitable as a wife and
my favorite
uppity huh uppity i wonder why they
chose that word
i think i can explain in a segment
called how did we get here
listen i'll be the first to admit that
i'm not quite up
on my british culture until recently i
thought earl was a title bestowed on the
oldest man in any auto mechanics shop
but i do know a dog whistle when i hear
one a dog whistle is coded language
that's used to insult a group of people
while maintaining deniability to the
audience at large
dog whistles use language that sounds
normal to the majority of people but
that communicates a very specific
very shitty message to a smaller
intended audience
for example the dictionary definition of
uppity is self-important or
arrogant but that word is exclusively
used to describe
black people who supposedly don't know
their place
i've never heard a white person be
called uppity in my entire life
but then again i work in television so
maybe i just don't know any
self-important white people
so when you say uppity you can pretend
you're just calling someone
self-important in a race neutral way but
we all know what you're really saying is
that they think of themselves
too highly for a black person it
especially gets used to describe black
people who asked to be treated the same
as white people
which isn't a lot to ask especially when
you're a literal freaking princess
isn't finding yourself important exactly
what being royal is
oh so only white princesses get to order
birds to brush their hair
let megan have her birds there are a
million dog whistles like this and
they all essentially mean a different
version of the same thing
so when tabloids call meghan markle
uppity or exotic
or duchess difficult what they're really
saying is
she's black and we don't like that and
it makes us crazy when you're black and
fancy because
fancy is supposed to be our thing but
dog whistles aren't just a british thing
americans might not be great at men's
fashion or men's soccer but
we are amazing at dog whistles like when
trump told voters that
low-income housing was going to destroy
the suburbs
he was saying black people are going to
move into your white neighborhoods and
you should be scared
they could season your food or teach
your women to dance
or when trump planned a rally in tulsa
on juneteenth
people who didn't know the significance
of tulsa were like okay
but racists heard that dog whistle and
we're like
as far as ways to be racist go dog
whistles are a great strategy for
politicians because
you get to be racist and pretend you're
not and when black people get mad about
the obvious racism you get to call them
politically correct for canceling you
over something you definitely
wink wink weren't doing you get to have
your racist
cake and eat it too and you know that
cake is dry as hell and the kitchen was
not clean when they made it
and if you're wondering if there are dog
whistles that exclusively apply to white
people
well there are and they're my favorite
kind if you hear anyone say patriots
they're talking about white people or
the new england football team which in
which case they're still talking about
white people
when politicians say working class they
mean working-class white people also
known as blue-collar people
diner patrons or bruce springsteen fans
black voters are
black voters but white voters are soccer
moms or nascar dads or evangelicals or
value voters apparently
only white people play soccer or have
values
just don't say white people they hate
that because white people are people
they get to have
individuality and complex backstories
that you have to empathize with in order
to understand their choices
and when black people ask to be treated
that way we're uppity
there are too many of these terms for me
to cover if you want to learn them all
you'll have to download duolingo
or you can just read one single article
about meghan markle cause they're all in
there
and while we're back on the subject i'd
like to take a second to talk about
megan and harry using absolutely no dog
whistles
megan and harry are grown-ups who can do
whatever they want
they are hot and young and rich and they
know oprah
but most importantly they are minding
their own dang business
meghan markle's life literally does not
affect you in any way
so if you hate megan you need to take a
hard look
at yourself and ask why is it because
she ruined your high school fantasy of
marrying a prince who never knew you
existed
or is it that the world has taught you
that black girls are worthless and
seeing megan being loved so fiercely
makes you angry
harry would rather be her husband than
your prince and it makes you sick
meghan markle is smart and classy and
brave and she's a better princess than
we deserve
and if you're mad at her if you think
you deserve a better princess than her
that's the definition of uppity this has
been how do we get here
[Music]
[Applause]
you